[Music]
come on you're okay come on oh my god
you see what the patch on yes what
happened well I had the surgery and I
have to recover now and make sure that
nothing happens to my eye but I'm ready
to go we're still under this pageant
okay were you looking good spirits yeah
I've got a lot of obstacles in my life
right now I have an eye for them and
check it later on with my doctor I'm
kind of worried about what he's gonna
say but I'm gonna show everyone that I'm
gonna get through it and do this damn
pageant let's say you know we're not
moving into where we're actually gonna
start doing some walking
let's try wheels yes touch him
see mmm they're not too bad that's about
it all I must really want to win this
pageant I mean you get your feet ran
over by four lived and you try to put on
some damn Hill they ain't gonna work I
mean I don't believe I'm allowing you to
let me put on the heels
well at least we have a walker boom you
know what a walker
[Music]
I'm not [ __ ] 80 yeah but I don't need
to hurt yourself either so it's just
there in case you need it
it's probably a good thing that Nick's
brought that walker cuz mama
is old she's almost 40
[Music]